[Music]
Steve have you heard and I'm sure you
have
of course yes I love it have you heard
about this one US soldier who allegedly
gave classified information to satanic
neo-nazis with the goal of starting a
new war no but stones a lot of words say
to me Oh nuts
who's this one his name is Ethan Meltzer
a private in the US Army and [ __ ] was he
no no that's nothing they're describing
him and private isn't that like the bay
beginning he's a [ __ ] em1 or was a
[ __ ] toilet scrubber what does he
know and he stole it off a generals desk
so the soldier allegedly provided this
one group with his units location
strength travel routes and weaponry as
soon as he found out that he was gonna
be deployed to Turkey I believe yes
Turkey and so he started to plan his
attack on his unit his only way yes cuz
he didn't wanna go to Turkey no because
he wanted to continue the war and like
make it prolong so he was a Jew to spy
joining the army already pretty much it
was a plan before he became are you
satanic well he beat he joins us in
group he joined this one group a year
later after so they're saying that he
joined the US Army in 2018 and a year
later that's when he joined this
extremist group it's called nine order
of the nine angles or o98 and so they
are white supremacist group math club
you're not that second a man yeah even
better order the nine angles I always
liked the name the Aryan Brotherhood
that's way way sicker but it's like it's
it's it sounds like a ancient hangout or
mean you know but then if it's just that
it's like a five five four or whatever
and zero zero four nine it's like man
you're trying to be a little too
futuristic like Elon Musk right now I'm
trans order of something like order of
the nine ISM [ __ ] is o order the nine
over nine six nights of the ninth o
night to the ninth [ __ ] say yeah
that's very Aryan two nights of the zero
table
oh [ __ ] cuz it's like a circle but it's
a zero every brand I know maybe they
watch this and they're like you know
what why don't we think of that but what
if the what if the Aryan graphic
designers I [ __ ] I spent all this time
making these cool t-shirts he's like
it's so hard though cuz I I can't use my
mouse cuz I'm doing I'm trying to do the
zig Heil the whole time so like it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't know how extremist these people
are I'm scared in this video anyway so
members of this white supremacist group
they according to federal prosecutors
are saying that there they espoused
violent neo-nazi anti-semitic and
satanic beliefs and have expressed
admiration for both Nazis and Islamic
jihadists and so they're similar they
admire the enemy so that's why yeah I
thought we're not like they are not
supposed to like anyone that's not white
the white the widest of the white like
eggshell white yeah interesting
please go further maybe they're becoming
more open-minded that's sick though why
is the premises group that admire Islam
Islamic terrorism yeah they they admire
you know Hitler and which is class Alma
someone in Latin just weird that is new
have they seen bin Laden are they aware
they might not know a white picture and
let o you look away he looks like a nice
fellow
she's a biker with a beard maybe they
can pull inspiration from other cultures
but they still hate them and feel that
they're superior to them social creation
this is what okay so investigators claim
in court documents that this group has
expressed belief in the inequality of
races that Hitler was sent by our God's
to guide us to greatness and that the
Holocaust was a lie
and an oh nine a Holocaust never
happened in their history never exist
cussin tires
they just put a bunch of shoes there and
they also said that they have craved the
Nazis for the practical expression of
this satanic spirit and held that the
world has become perverted by among
other things judeo-christian beliefs and
they're the leading members of the group
they are plotting to overthrow Western
civilization what I'm confused well okay
I know that there is a group of
Satanists that actually believe that
Lucifer is the good guy and that
Christianity in the Catholic Church is
the bad guy and in they perverted
history and rewrote it and it's actually
reversed so I kind of get where he's
coming from if he believes in that
school of thought same in a way cuz I
think that the Catholic Church has been
co-opted because they were covering up
for the pedophile [ __ ] and so I don't
know yeah I don't think they have a good
rep so I think they are evil in a way
because they cover it up for that [ __ ]
pervasively like at all tears but these
guys are taking it to a level that it's
like nuts
yeah so they're saying that this guy the
soldier that we're talking about that he
was trying to instigate a jihadi attack
during his deployment to kill his fellow
service members and he even said they're
saying that when they brought up that he
might also get killed he said who gives
a [ __ ] I would have died successfully
for extremist yeah and then he says
another ten year war in the Middle East
would definitely leave a mark well I
mean you know there's a Venn diagram of
beliefs here that I'm bumping up against
cuz I'm like yeah that sucks I don't
want another ten year war in the Middle
East
hey yeah the economy well yeah that's
why yeah so he he wants more destruction
and he wants he's just trying to keep
more war from him he wants he thinks
that killing his own platoon means that
the war will end sooner which is why
he's trying to continuing it oh I think
I thought he's trying to drag it out
repeat the court no 10-year work he said
another ten year war in the Middle East
would definitely leave a mark leave a
mark
I thought it meant like this is
something that I'm doing positively good
yeah leave a mark like this is gonna be
oh yeah no because he's trying to start
a race war or continual race war right
yeah he's just trying to yeah and so
he's saying that he they're saying this
article like he believed the attack
would cause a new war because of the
number of deaths Jesus to his unit you
said their goal is to and Western what
now the Western civilization overthrow
Western civilization what is I'm
confused too guy I'm confused as to his
unit to start enough just to continue a
war yeah to kill more Westerners yeah
wait is it
Nazism Western thinking or no it's not
what is it considered like these guys
have hated so much they've hated full
circle back it's like hey why people so
much our America to die one so Western
think it's like Adam Smith like you know
the invisible hand like all this other
[ __ ] like not this not like this oh okay
okay I get it it's because capitalism
Eastern or like calm it was communism
versus Western get her up yeah right
that's what they means okay because I'm
thinking like the West as in European
philosophy and European inventions
because I even bug you like I even put
communism under European fire right like
Eastern Western philosophy to me so that
okay that because they used to call like
that the Eastern Bloc the Communists and
everybody oh so that's where they okay
and then yeah the Nazis were socialists
and they were not yet where they were
nationalist socialist so they they're
not Western so yeah that makes sense
so they're also reporting in this
article that he was keeping tabs on
other members of the military who were
recently arrested for allegedly plotting
attacks the same way he was and linky
and these were linked to white
supremacist groups as well so he ended
up writing and one of the one of the
messages saying don't want to end up
like that
f-word from who got caught while he was
in the military
bad [ __ ]
so he was just saying but he got caught
right how did they kiss oh this is I'm
not sure I'm not sure exactly what went
down that tipped off the FBI but
eventually the FBI and military
investigators interviewed him and he
just straight up like admitted it you're
just like yeah so very good at this job
he declared himself a traitor of the
u.s. and like I said he admitted to his
role and everything was in the Brig no
like military prison so they're saying
that he's charged with conspiring to
murder US Nationals attempting to murder
US Nationals and conspiring to murder
murder US military service members as
well as attempting to provide in
providing material support to terrorists
and conspiring to murder and maim in a
foreign country among other federal
charges so they're saying if he is
convicted he faces life in prison
dude this cat's his worst on lawyer he's
like hey real quick you forgot Satanism
while abroad I also was a Satanist while
abroad that's a charge he's like wait a
minute you forgot about that one crime
but did you guys like you guys listen to
me so that's all Tori what about all the
other people that were involved I mean
they're also getting arrested it to
himself out
it'll probably rat them out so there are
white supremacists in our military yeah
oh sure
Wow part that kind of gets me feeling
confused is like why attack your own
country I don't think they think it's
their own country because they think
it's their country betrayed them their
country has black people also stuff in
the military so too then they're like
that's an effrontery or whatever yeah
that'll be that they define the country
as like geographical borders anymore
it's more of ideals their people their
race but then how do they love bin Laden
I'm like okay there's some crossover
here that we're missing they may be
worried current too frankly because I
don't know what the [ __ ] how you get
there yeah it's difficult because
traditionally in my mind whenever I
heard the term white supremacist
right I would think Nazism in their
philosophy but that term has changed so
much because it's used so frivolously
for everything but then when I think of
the term white supremacy I think of
someone who believes in mine COFF and
what wasn't Hitler believed and their
anti-semitic and they believed that the
Jewish conspiracy is Jews control the
world controlling the world and all that
people are the best everybody else's
should be showed subjugated by whites
and and and that's supposed to be the
ground root philosophy of Nazism and all
that but then like now the way that it's
just uses the white patriarchy is white
supremacism everything is white
supremacism now yeah but it kind of to
me what it does is it muddies up the
dangers of Nazism it destroys the
argument because now the word white
supremacy doesn't have the same weight
as Nazism did you if that makes any
sense
you yells well right so when you muddy
it down right through to the point where
you're like Uncle Ben's rice is part of
white supremacy that makes the argument
sillier then if it was just about how
you know redlining happened and that was
all fine and how we used the CIA to move
drugs into the inner cities and we did
that purposefully and also like a lot of
the AIDS stuff that happened was ignored
because of where it was impacted which
is low-income people like if you can
make the argument sillier than that and
go like hey take an aunt jemima out and
like that's white supremacy aunt jemima
with white supremacy then it makes
everything connected to real silly
problems of white supremacy negated it's
the same SIOP is like hey I saw UFO and
then somebody's like you mean you saw a
little green men and like no I just saw
non-identified flying object couldn't
explain it and people like oh well I'm
dumbing it down to the point where you
saw a little green man and so it makes
everything sillier yeah anyone ever
raise their hand at a meeting and said
hey I know that we're like white
supremacists
but are we not supposed to like I know
yo I gotta probably this bin lying
I think anyone I just want to know like
just so we're clear Kiwi but in there
little by the way I get your argument he
holds a coalition a car pretty cool he
holds it well unless the leaders like
Clayton bit to be you can't see
[Music]